live streaming
hello everyone and welcome this is team
com
podcast 4.1 on september 15th
2020. welcome to everybody hello all
participants
i'm going to share my screen and we will
jump
right in this is team com podcast
4.1 and
this is team com teamcom is an
experiment
in online team communication and
learning related to
active inference you can find us on
twitter at
inferenceactive you can email us
you can find us on the public key base
team as well as at
the youtube channel this is a recorded
and
archived live stream so please provide
us with any
feedback participants as well as viewers
so that we can improve our work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here
and also just on a note of video
etiquette if people are
muted in a noisy background or raising
their hands when there's this many
participants in the chat
it would be excellent and help us with
our turn taking and reduction of
uncertainty
about who's to speak next so here we are
in stream 4.1 and the structure of today
is going to go like this
first we're going to have a few check-in
questions and
warm-up discussion then we'll get to the
paper itself
which is ramstead at all 2016. we'll
talk about the big aims of the paper
go through a roadmap of the paper to see
how the authors get from a to z
we'll go through the abstract to
understand how the authors represent
their own work
then we'll go through the box of
definitions as well as the figures
at that point we'll have time for
questions and other insights
and also we've implicitly prepared for a
podcast 4.2 where we'll be able to have
further discussions on some key
quotations or anything arising that we
don't get to
this week so thanks for that part here
we are in the check-in and everybody can
feel free to introduce themselves in
their location if they would like
the first question is pretty broad but
that's what the warm-up is about so
what is culture
it's a good question
or in the sense of this paper in the
sense of culture that's being scaffolded
within a kind of framework that we might
want to build out
what would that kind of culture refer to
well so i'm maxwell ramstad i'm uh
the first author on this paper cultural
affordances
um by the way i'm really grateful uh
for this uh podcast you all have been so
great just in general over the last few
weeks and i'm
i'm particularly touched that you're
giving uh the work that we've developed
so much attention
um and it's like just i'm just so full
of gratitude
this is so cool um so culture
at least in the sense that we're using
uh
the term here means something like the
taken for granted
i think is sort of the heuristic way
that i like to think about it
it's sort of like in a given local frame
of reference
uh in a given environment shared by a
group of people
a living together what are the things
that are taken for granted what are the
uh sets of expectations and beliefs and
sets of practices and norms um
you know that that are shared and that
essentially
uh structure people's intuitive grip on
their shared social world
any other thoughts on culture there yeah
in sociology uh we define culture it's
kind of three different dimensions
you have the symbolic ideal dimension
which is really i think equivalent to or
equivalent to
semantic knowledge uh we break it up in
terms of norms values and beliefs
uh we have a psychobehavioral dimension
which is really about in body culture
how your body moves
um the skills that you have in in terms
of psychological kind of
terminology i would really say your
skills and habits um
in in kind of that non-declarative
memory sense
and then the third dimension is really
our material dimensions of the physical
things that we create the tools the
buildings the fashion
um which i think the degree to which i
understand the affordance literature i
think all three of those dimensions
definitely have versions of affordances
that could connect to that
um i think that was one thing i did see
in the paper that
it did seem to be very much focused on
just that semantic
kind of symbolic dimension and not
really uh explicitly incorporating the
other dimensions that
at least in sociology we would kind of
um
include in that definition of culture
cool yeah thanks for that that was very
rich actually
uh very interesting uh points that
you're raising
yeah i should just give some maybe some
historical background
on this paper this was the first in a
series of papers that have been
developed
into basically like a a variational or
free energy approach to culture
and i think a lot of the elements that
you're mentioning
were only sketched in this paper
uh and were developed in i think further
iterations of the model
uh so everything that you're that you
just outlined uh
richard i think are are very essential
and crucial
things that need to be tackled when
studying culture so
it's great that you're raising them cool
and i think the question about multiple
kinds of culture
ranging from the semantic concepts to
the
externalized productions or the
artifacts of culture
bring us this idea of scaffolding
culture so what is a way
that culture is scaffolded someone can
raise their hand maybe someone new but
something that
guides the construction just like a
scaffold
i'll give one way which is education
because pedagogy is sort of the
guide rails for how individuals learn
about those
norms as well as how to use the
artifacts
and construct new artifacts these are
ways in which culture is scaffolded
because it provides structure
for the growth to happen within
any other comments on that
okay and then the last warm-up question
is what is shared intentionality
or what's a way in which somebody has
seen shared intentionality play out in
their
recent experience
well so there are two parts to that
right there's shared and there's
intentionality
so intentionality at least in the sense
that we're using it in the paper draws
on
the philosophical construct of
intentionality that we we can
basically uh you know
you can draw a lineage all the way back
to brentano effectively but
so by intentionality we mean orientation
towards the world
uh we don't necessarily mean
intentionality in the sense of
uh having the intention to do this or
that
it really it's from the latin i think
intensio
which is the word that was used to
describe what a
uh what an archer is doing with his
arrow
uh to hit the target it is intensio
with the target and so it it it's this
that we're trying to
get at and one of the things that we're
trying to argue here is that what
part of what makes um a shared social
world
just that a shared social world is that
there are forms of relating to that
world so forms of intentionality that
are
also shared uh among the
the people who live in that world
together so that's that's what we were
trying to
get at ultimately i think and i think
what's interesting in terms of
if you take that definition and you look
back at the scaffolding
um you know if you look within the
individual there's this network of
semantic and episodic memory
and non-declarative memory that's
organized in the brain if you put me in
contact with another individual from my
culture who shares my language
and we begin to construct this we space
if you look at
the phenomenology um and then now what
happens with
this dyad either we introduce a third
person or we then one of us leaves the
relationship and we go
uh interact with someone else if you
spread that dyadic interaction out to a
network
and then you look at the fractal scaling
of that network there's this way to i
think to very deliberately keep track
and build up
from organized memory and brain to an
institution of 25
000 people dynamically interacting by
following this
this these mechanisms by which you
create the shared space and looking at
those emerging properties
and trying to model them mathematically
couldn't agree
and there's a quote from the paper which
i'll spare maxwell from reading is
uh near the end it says to address more
complex social situations
it is useful to revise current
sociocognitive models of joint attention
to encompass fundamentally triadic
situations
in which the third is the socially
constituted niche of affordances
supported by local ontologies and
abilities so we're just jumping in
today but that's sort of where we're
wanting to go with this paper and in
discussion
is towards understanding what is that
third space and how does the aim or does
the intent
play in yeah stephen
yeah and i think this cultural thing
also brings in that into subjectivity
it gives a way to understand how to
approach it beyond education
beyond sort of the banking of
programming people saying well what's in
the environment particularly now that
we've got situations of
cross-cultural what cultures have to try
and
understand and work together is it all
about teaching us
how to tolerate each other or is it
about understanding
how we perform in the environment so i
think it's got a lot of
well here we are finally at the paper uh
cultural affordances scaffolding local
worlds
through shared intentionality and
regimes of attention so we'll definitely
want to unpack each of these
concepts and it's in frontiers in
psychology from 2016.
the big aim of the paper grasped from
the abstract in the
introduction section is to better
understand how culture and context
interact with human biology
to shape human behavior cognition and
experience
so kind of all of it kind of things that
richard was bringing up early on
and from the introduction the
integrative framework we propose
bridges cognitive and social sciences to
provide two things
first an expanded concept of affordance
that extends to socio-cultural forms of
life
which will unpack in box one and two a
multi-level
account of the socio-culturally
scaffolded forms of affordance learning
and the transmission of affordances in
pattern sociocultural practices
so the key piece there is that
multi-level account
because we're not going to have an
individual level account by which
collective outcomes arise
or a group level account by which
individuals are shaped in their behavior
uniquely those are sort of two sides of
the same coin or
some of the sides of a many-sided coin
that constitute
this top down and bottom-up relationship
that we see in a lot of multi-scale
systems like
the brain being nested within a body
inside of a niche
inside of these institutions that last
beyond the lifespan
of the organism any thoughts on the aim
here or questions about anything
cool well then let's get to the roadmap
so the roadmap
i just copied out the section headers
how that takes us on a journey or on a
narrative
in our learning odyssey in a sense in
the beginning there's an introduction
and a theoretical framework for
affordances is provided
and that includes i know the font may be
a little small perspectives importances
and phenomenology
landscapes and fields meanings and
affordances
and then we reach figure one which has a
basic cognitive formula
for automatic intentionality and figure
two that expands on that
formula slash comment format so that's a
theoretical framework for affordances
maybe could anyone chime in what what is
an affordance
in this uh context or in the cultural
context or in the context of whichever
field you're familiar with
yeah so i guess just for a simple
definition it's something that invites
action or interaction
and the the cartoon example is always a
chair a ford sitting
um but in the context of a social
interaction it could be some
environment that affords or that elicits
our
interaction maybe conversation or music
making with another person
great and it makes sense to start the
paper off with this framework for
affordances because action
opportunities are so fundamental to
active inference
and to action-oriented frameworks this
is really what defines
action-oriented frameworks is they focus
on actions
and the stimuli or the cues that lead to
action
so affordance is their opportunity the
second
section here is the neurodynamics of
affordances so this is the integration
of the cognitive and the neurosciences
with
the more behavioral ecological concept
of an affordance
computation representation and minimal
neural models
is addressed and also many of these
ideas later papers
include other or different depictions
and this is already four years past so
that equates to about 400 papers in
between us and here
yeah i should say um like this is
probably the weakest section of the
paper
as it currently is formulated
um i mean yeah as you're pointing out it
was published in 2016 and we started
really working on this in 2015
and i mean since i did a whole phd
focused on the free energy principle
and uh what it what it entails and how
it works
and so on and i think uh
i i mean i wouldn't disavow what we say
here
uh but i think that definitely
our our understanding of the
representational implications
of the theory have been refined over the
years
but i mean this this is basically in a
nutshell what we tried to pursue
since 2016 so as you're saying like
several papers have been published since
um and the uh you know
the the the framework has moved a little
bit
absolutely richard yeah i think i mean
definitely whenever we look back on our
earlier papers we're always like i
should have said all these different
things
but i i actually really appreciate this
paper because you know for reading
it just as a complete non-expert in a
lot of these fields
um the free energy principle is very
very difficult to find an entry point
into
and sort of have something that i think
is very conceptual
and grounded in neuroscience i think a
lot of social sciences could wrap their
head around
you know relatively easily and then to
trace this as breadcrumbs to the more
advanced
um free energy principle stuff um i i
really appreciate i thought it was a
great entry point into this literature
and kind of gave me a
you know a foundation to kind of start
to wrap my head around how these
these concepts are being applied in that
more mathematical context
you're saying that it's one of the
reasons why we
chose this paper other than shannon
suggesting it is
for me at least when i can see the path
in the literature
well okay here's what they thought in
2016 which means in years leading up to
and then yes it can be refined or
represented or enriched in later
work but seeing the breadcrumbs or the
pheromone trail
is how i get a calibration of the
derivatives of how the ideas are
changing
through time and i found that um yeah
one way maybe
weaker but the most growth has happened
here and this is one of the areas where
the most growth can happen
so this is why we continue to dip back
into the literature
even longer than four years in the past
i know it feels like forever though
because sometimes there's a uniqueness
to that cultural artifact that
isn't just about how well it conveys
what the relationship is between
neuroscience and free energy
but rather how well it conveys the what
the researchers were working on
in that intersection so we're thinking
through other minds for some of us it
was us in the past for some of us
it was just another paper yeah and i
will say this just really quick too
a lot of the affordances that concept of
affordance in sociology is very much
grounded in kind of a pragmatic
process philosophy you know whitehead
the idea that you know reality reaches
out to the other reality
and so if you if if that is where our
literature is grounded
to be able to have something like this
that's very conceptual to work through
those philosophical ramifications
and then begin to ask how would this fit
with uh the free energy principle
and i think vice versa as well having
the free energy principle community
kind of understanding some of these
philosophical concepts and ideas
to kind of ground more conceptually not
so much mathematically what it is that
their
perspective is offering to other
disciplines
well said then we move to
figure three now i found that figure
three four
and five make a really nice sequence and
we'll go through them in
sequence because it enriches one level
of detail
on top of one level of detail of a
hierarchical prediction error
minimization framework
figure four diagrams it a little bit
more clearly from a bayesian perspective
and then five brings on another level of
realism
then we talk a little bit in this
section about predictive processing and
attention
and that returns our attention to the
idea of culture
as regimes of attention from the title
at this point if i had to rewrite this
paper this would be two papers and
this would be the split so i really
think that
the first part of the paper really uh
tells a story about affordances uh
affordances the affordances that are
avail available in the
human landscape uh you know in terms of
their depend the dependence of certain
kinds of affordance on convention
whereas others are more just dependent
on the kind of spontaneous
you know action biology of human bodies
and then the second half of the paper
turns to this concept of attention
and with with all this in place says
okay so how is culture
acquired in these what we're calling
regimes of attention which are
effectively shared patterns
of allocating your attention to this
rather than that as being salient
so and this all is bit you can read this
as kind of computational goffman
uh for richard who's done comes from
sociology
uh yet it's an attempt to kind of spell
out
how what would a mechanistic model
of you know regimes of like civic
inattention
and so on look like effectively uh when
you're trying to bridge these different
levels
but you know i think there's a lot in
this paper and this is a good kind of
split point if you want to see what the
paper is doing effectively
nice very helpful for us because it just
reads
as a turing tape to those who are
reading it line by line but to know that
there's a conceptual demarcation
is helpful and regimes of attention i
just think is a great term to capture it
because it's kind of like well where's
the regime it's everywhere and it's
nowhere it just
is the water that culture is existing
within
in this section we have figure 6 of a
diagram of the looping effects or the
rolling loops
that mediate cultural affordance
learning
there's a discussion of skilled
intentionality and affordance
competition with some nice citations to
other work
about the skilled intentionality
framework
there's a section on shared expectations
local ontologies and cultural
affordances
and we think a lot about ontologies here
and about the words that we use to
locally organize
our thought and cultures this kind of
multi-scale
ontology that helps organize stimuli
in a sense and the section closes with
a discussion of shared expectation and
implicit learning
then the last section major section of
the paper is the regimes of shared
attention and shared intentionality
reflecting gating abilities and
affordances
and moving the loop regimes of shared
attention and skilled intentionality
before a conclusion so that
is the roadmap that's how you get from
discussion of the ecological
psychological or
behavioral inactive concept of an
affordance
then into the neuroscience of
affordances and then
as suggested by maxwell there's a bit of
a intermission
conceptually here before turning to a
second half of the paper
that has to do with the actual ways in
which culture is scaffolded through
these regimes
of expectations and attention any
questions on the roadmap
cool all right here we are in the
abstract
which i often find helpful to read
because
i know that authors put a lot of care
into the abstract because
it represents to the in group to the
field as well as to the out group to the
reviewers to the editor to the reader
it reflects what the paper is going to
be about and people get
surprised and even disappointed when the
abstract is
off base relative to what the paper
actually delivers on
they write in this paper we outline a
framework
for the study of mechanisms involved in
the engagement of human agents with
cultural affordances which we're going
to define soon
our aim is to better understand how
culture and context interact with human
biology to shape human behavior
cognition and experience we attempt to
integrate several related approaches in
the study of the embodied
cognitive and affective substrates of
sociality and culture
and the socio-cultural scaffolding of
experience
that's the first half the abstract then
they write
the integrative framework we propose is
we propose
bridges cognitive and social sciences to
provide
one an expanded concept of affordance
that extends to sociocultural forms of
life
and two a multi-level account of the
socioculturally scaffolded forms of
affordance learning and the transmission
of affordances in a patterned
socio-cultural practices and regimes of
shared attention
the framework provides an account of how
cultural content and normative practices
are built on a foundation of contentless
basic mental processes
definitely something we'll return to the
acquire content
through immersive participation of the
agent in social practices that regulate
joint attention and shared
intentionality
okay any thoughts on the abstract or
questions before we turn to the box
cool well box one i thought it would be
helpful just to
list out the terms of the different
types of affordances then go
through them what is an example of each
of these
kinds of affordances or what are the
differences between these types of
affordances
so maybe we could start there if someone
could raise their hand and
pick one of these types of affordances
natural cultural or conventional
and then define uh what it means to them
or an example of it
yep maxwell um well
essentially what we're suggesting is
that
well cultural affordances by the way um
i i just noticed that my um
my camera is frozen is that the case for
everyone as well
your screen looks dark you can either
toggle the camera on and off or just
reload the page
um after talking i might try to rejoin
just so the camera
freezes um yeah so what we're
essentially arguing is that
in humans all affordances are at least
minimally cultural in the sense that i
mean i don't know about you but
as i was growing up uh my mother told me
not to slouch
uh while i was at at the dinner table
uh and so you know it's something as
simple and natural
as sitting um does actually come with a
cultural scaffold
and what we're saying is that there's
basically a spectrum of affordances
you can think about the space of
affordances with his with which humans
interact
as going on a kind of continuum from
natural to conventional
where natural affordances depend mainly
just on the biophysics of the human body
in its interaction with the environment
whereas conventional affordances depend
on
these implicit or explicit sets
of uh conventions or shared beliefs
uh so you know an example of the latter
would be
um a king's throne right you don't sit
on the king's throne unless
you're a very specific agent uh so
a king's throne doesn't afford sitting
uh for everyone in the same way that say
just a chair
or a stool might afford sitting there
there are conventions shared conventions
uh the kind of uh structure
which affordances are available uh and
which are not
for a given agent
cool richard yeah i was just curious
in the neuroscience about like actually
distinguishing that so if i
if i see a cup my mirror neuron system
fires and i begin to kind of enact
the act of reaching out and grabbing it
but then semantically i know that you
know
as a a lowly surf i'm not allowed to
touch that
is there actually any research showing
the conflict between
semantic knowledge about you know and
self-related knowledge that i'm not
allowed to do that
with the automatic kind of reaching out
mirror neuron system simulation of
touching the cup that's really
interesting i'm not sure
i i don't know if there's any data about
this particularly
it would be very interesting though one
thought i had was
some experiments i believe by michael
von elk with hands grasping cups at
incorrect ways so it's something when
you're here and you're on c oh that's
not how you're supposed to grab a cup
well why not
well because i can't rotate my wrist
again to drink it so it's the wrong way
to hold it because it's not really a cup
of water
if i can't drink from it in that
functional affordance based
sense but i agree it would be
interesting and we'll follow up on that
and stephen did you have any class
yeah i actually had a workshop when i i
was working with a group with um
who with disability who um and i
mentioned about affordances as part of
it
and partly having done this paper and
one of the participants she was saying
how when she sees a cup because she
can't pick it up
and she doesn't see it as a cup unless
it's one that's got a handle that she
can reach her hand into
and do that so that kind of sense of
things presenting is quite true and i
like this breakdown because
the i get a sense that the following on
from the later work that maxwell did
like natural affordances is like you
know if there's a cliff it doesn't
afford me to walk any further
whereas cultural is a bit more of like
this mixing sort of egotic
kind of space where it's conventional
it's like the the throne it's like
it's not up for negotiation it's like
you don't sit on the chair it's like a
fixed rule there's no
kind of inter-subjective piece going on
so in some ways the cultural piece seems
to have
some sort of negotiation associated with
it which is quite
quite cool would it be accurate to say
that that in a sense of
if if i i had the simulation to reach
out and grab the cup
but then my semantic memory says no
we're not allowed to do that could that
almost be like a prediction error in the
sense of like i'm predicting that i'm
going to do this well no
we don't do that precisely and the way
that you would do that
is probably by having a hierarchical
model where basically you know so the
the notion of hierarchy i mean it has
political implications and we can kind
of ditch those
uh so i prefer thinking about it in
terms of center and periphery
right where like the the periphery is
the the end of it that's closer to the
sensory motor like interactions and the
center
is something more like you know what we
would think of as the top of
uh of a processing hierarchy where
representations are
progressively more compressed uh so
if you look at the hierarchy from from
periphery to center or from bottom to
top
what you have represented there uh if
you'll allow me the
language of representation for a second
we can finesse it later but what's
essentially represented there
is as you progress towards the center
slower
and slower or more and more abstract
regularities
so you might think that yeah as you see
the chair at a kind of more
automatic uh kind of a sensory motor
level
you you see it as something that you
could sit on but as that
ascends the processing hierarchy at some
point it registers an error as in like
semantically i'm not allowed
to sit on this because it's a king's
chair so
precisely that's how that would work as
and you can you can accommodate for this
kind of conflict by allowing the system
to have a layered or hierarchical
structure
and great point and this relates to how
it's a spectrum
of affordances so for example a violin
when i look at a violin i have the
biophysics to bend my fingers
but i can't play violin so i see an
affordance for something i could pick up
potentially and not everybody may see
that affordance
however somebody else sees that and
culturally they think oh i could play
this
uh song or i could play that song and so
what song they see
the device as being able to be used for
is going to be part of their
enculturation part of their education
which builds upon the biophysics of the
human body
and that's why we have different dance
styles in different places
from different cultures even though
everybody's elbows
still move the same way sasha
yeah so in trying to understand
affordances
um i tend to think of it as like
the space of what is allowed but in
walking through the different kinds of
um affordances that we have um it
becomes pretty clear that
it's not just what is allowed it's very
strongly gated by the top-down priors of
what you think should be allowed
in your space and it just kind of
reminds me of this
um anecdotal understanding of how
children
interact with an environment versus
adults and
how children would use or sit on objects
that adults would never think of sitting
on
and kind of the the different ways that
they
see and use the world um because they
don't have these
top-down priors of um what one
should and should not do and so
that that's a nice way of um kind of
circling back to the point of this paper
that
um everything is embedded in culture and
you don't just start from
kind of the biophysics of sitting and
work your way up
you're always going back and forth with
this is uh this is
such a great point thank you for thank
you for uh pointing that out sasha like
the the agenda here is to
uh pursue this kind of
excuse me this kind of cooperative turn
in the anthropology literature which is
to say that
um you know as joseph henrich
who's one of my uh one of my favorite
like anthropologists
uh psychologists uh out there as he
points
as he puts it we've crossed the
evolutionary rubicon
in a way our our survival as
humans depends on our ability to
reliably
access and use uh stored
cultural information effectively and
that's had an
influence on the way that our biology
has evolved so you know compared to
chimps for example we have uh
really weak digestive juices and that's
because we've
we've been able to offload the metabolic
cost of you know having this extremely
elaborate digestive system uh
to our technology effectively you know
so tool use the use of fire cooking
technology
has allowed us to process food in a way
that then co-evolves with our bodies
and takes the kind of processing load of
the food uh
off the body itself towards these
cultural artifacts and practices
that have co-evolved with our biology
and that's really the the point is that
uh all human affordances are cultural
affordances
which exist on a spectrum from more
natural to more conventional but
human biology is a cultural biology and
biologic
and yeah culture is a biological
phenomenon
i think that the two are kind of
irreconcilably joined
in the case of humans and i'll build on
that to
describe the difference between the
field and the landscape of affordance
sorry i meant insurmountably you're uh
irreducibly joy not not here uh
yeah sorry oh yeah it works so the field
of affordances
are the affordances in the landscape
with which the organism
can dynamically cope and intelligently
adapt so that's at an organismal
level the field of affordances is like
the field of play it's the field of
action
for that agent the landscape of
affordances on the other hand like the
landscape exists
beyond me even when i can't interact
with it directly
and similarly the landscape of
affordances
is defined here as the total ensemble of
available affordances for a population
in a given environment and so the
concept of chair
just as sasha was bringing up the
landscape
of affordances of chairs includes things
for little people
for tall people for people with small
hands for larger hands
the landscape of affordances is at the
population level
which means it includes all these
differences that are biophysical and
developmental and cultural as well
so the field is what one individual
agent is able to interact with
and that's sort of where the rubber hits
the road of action-oriented frameworks
and then when we pull back a level to
this evolutionary perspective on
action-oriented frameworks
we get to this landscape of affordance's
idea
any thoughts on that
yes stephen yeah i think that that
way that things are embedded it comes
back to that piece with the throne as
well is
where where that chair is for it to be
ascribed as a throne that you don't sit
on
is partly processed by what's going on
around
in that setting at that moment like if
there's no one around and it's an empty
room
you may sit on the chair if you don't
think anyone's going to see you
but when the cultural kind of rules of
the game are in play
or if you see you know if it was a room
where there's only children in there
compared to a room where there was an
adult watching
so there's this kind of negotiation
going on
um which is quite quite complex
and i think previously without free
energy i don't think there was a way to
be able to take that many different
parameters
and sort of integrate them
richard yeah i think what's really
fascinating too when we talk about this
is that
um the role of language in the role of
imitation and the role of just watching
other people where
i can walk into a room and know
absolutely nothing about the norms
values and beliefs that that
constrain it but if somebody just tells
me you know four or five words they can
immediately bring me up to speed
and kind of and to use the terminology
that sasha was using earlier
those top-down priors i can gain a
lifetime of experience
in 2500 words and watching four or five
people
seeing who's rewarded who's punished and
i think that i i
i'm curious to see and we don't have to
talk about this now but just you know
rhetorically i'm curious to see how can
you take in that notion of symbolic
communication
and quickly affect somebody's you know
prior understanding of situation
how do you fit that into a network of
free energy or agents running off this
free energy principle
and how does that is it like a
synchronization of oscillators on a
network like how exactly do you model
model that process yeah i'm just
imagining
you're walking with somebody to a
meeting and right before they open the
door
to reduce your uncertainty about what's
behind the door
they say hey it's going to be tense in
there or
hey just so you know it's a non-smoking
room and just like you're saying with
four or five words
the way that that person unpacks those
words
symbolically and the way that that
communication channel
is utilized to attune the agents on a
narrative
level that's what dictates how well
the scene is going to go when the room
is actually
being inactive and so there's so much
that we
tell each other when we're leading into
events that
that does set the tune and that has to
be unpacked within each person's
own perspective and also one bonus word
that's not here
but umvelt does anyone have a
sense of what that means but i figured i
just throw it out there as they sort of
complement to affordance
well if i can just uh comment on uh
richard's point uh before getting into
unveiled i think the way that you can
understand it from a free energy
perspective is uh i mean andy clark i
think and andrus robstorff has
have called this top top effects so
basically uh passing information from
the top
or the center of one's hierarchy to the
top of another
directly through these kinds of uh of
linguistic tokens that we're exchanging
i think that's uh that's a powerful
intuition
what we've done in more recent work is
extend that to a kind of horizontal
top kind of communication where it's
literally destruct the shared
physical structure of the niche whether
it's in the in terms of
shared artifacts like stories that we uh
create and and share with one another
that
so these uh effectively these
uh parts of models that are offloaded
onto the physical structure of the
environment can also come and have these
uh kind of
uh top-down structuring effects where
we're we're effectively installing
shared environmental priors at into the
top levels of our hierarchy through
enculturation
nice and how about maxwell what's your
take on him belt
i mean i think you know so i think those
of us
uh you know working in uh more
specifically on ecological psychology
we'll have some beef with the way that i
kind of uh just
generally put all of this together but i
think like you know
affordances umvelts uh phenomenology
i'm sure many people are not going to
agree with me so you know
feel free to discuss this but that
they're they're all perspectives on the
same kind of thing which is that if
we're trying to
talk about you know the meaning making
of organisms living organisms that share
a world
we can't uh we can't just not talk about
the first person perspective and the way
that meaning appears
from a specific vantage point and that's
sort of what the affordances
and umvelt stuff gets at uh
and effectively what we tried to do in
in this paper
and that's why i think it's it's the
kind of contribution to the broader
project of neurophenomenology is we we
start from
the kind of first-person perspective so
we
we're kind of trying to cash out you
know some some subtle
social effects like enculturation in
terms of learning affordances
and then we ask the question what's
going on under the hood and as it were
around
the hood uh for that kind of affordance
story
to be cashed out in mechanistic terms
uh so umvelt is a term uh by
a biologist i think it's pronounced von
ushakul
yeah and he uh i mean it's it's
essentially
it's very close to the uh the uh
affordances story
although it's it's more directly
centered on um
the perspective of the organism i mean
so gibsonians i should
say like uh you know the ecological
psychology was introduced by uh you know
jj gibson the famous psychologist and
a lot of ecological psychologists have
uh
take issue with our use of affordances
here
uh i think for interesting reasons the
so the
for for ecological psychologists the
idea is that perception is
the direct perception of a possibility
for
for well it's it's the directly we're
directly picking up information about
our environment like so
they're trying to emphasize that we
don't have to go through this elaborate
kind of
inference process there's a sense in
which like we just
directly read off the regularities in
our sensory array uh
what what what is possible and what is
doable and it so
in gibson's original formulation this is
what
affordances meant what we're doing is
more drawing on
tony camaro's reinterpretation of this
concept as affordances 2.0 he calls it
where an affordance is a relation
between some relevant features
of the environment and skills ultimately
you know expectations and skills had by
an organism so
this is already a a more inactive
embodied
reading of affordances and i mean we've
gotten
into some very interesting disagreements
with people from ecological psychology
precisely about this
difference in interpretation so i say
this because umvelt is very much focused
on
this kind of affordances 2.0 perspective
where what we're trying to do is really
capture what the world is like for the
organism that
inhabits it from its perspective
this is also where i think it connects
with phenomenology which is also this
kind of more systematic attempt
to describe things from the first person
perspective
great and that okay
alex first and then shannon
yeah thanks um as usual i'm trying to
connect uh to my domain is the
engineering domain
and it's more like a question about
could we consider importances from some
kind of
functionalities view as for example
if i need to drive in a nail
the hammer the provide provides me
affordance
to use it but if i don't have a hammer
i could use even microscope to do the
same
only one or two times but anyway for my
engineering task it could be enough
and if i see a chair and
it's provide the affordance to sit it's
like a basic function of the chair
to to to sit on it
so from this perspective how it could be
considered
like when agent need to do something and
need some kind of functionality
and this functionality or maybe service
to do it how it's possible link
oh absolutely this has been pursued by a
lot of work there's a really cool
group based in um in the netherlands
uh eric rietveld and julia keverstein in
particular
uh work from this perspective where eric
uh eric ridwell's work
is in architecture and affordances
so he he really tries to bring this
whole affordance's perspective
uh into the design of the spaces that we
live in
uh so what you're saying is totally uh
consonant with
uh at least some really interesting uses
of the
concept of affordances in the literature
since the early 2000s
cool shannon
i think yeah so i'm just thinking of
this
this field landscape difference and
umvelt
and it's really helpful considering
the perspective of the agent you're
investigating
especially um so i'm in music
neuroscience
so we can learn a lot about how people
or brains interact with music by putting
a person in an fmri scanner and
playing some music but that's not
exactly how we interact with music
in our day-to-day life maybe now more so
because we can turn on our ipod
and just sorry iphone we don't have
ipods anymore
um and listen to music alone as this
um solo endeavor but in general for
the history of human evolution music has
been this really interactive
participatory
activity and in order to understand
um from where i am how we interact with
understand or process music
it really is also a question of how we
understand and interact with
um other people and it's so when we
bring in these
um affordances we can have an affordance
for music um in a certain field that's
you know
us listening to music alone but as soon
as the landscape
is is a little bit bigger and maybe our
our small field
incorporates one other person or one
more other person
um then the perspective that we need to
take
needs to change to adapt the perspective
of each of those individuals or
of that musical sort of environment as a
whole
that's such a great point i don't know
if you're familiar with this paper that
i just linked
in the chat it's by anna anderson and
tom zimkia
uh called exploring the multi-layered
affordances of confor
of composing and performing interactive
music
with responsive technologies and it was
one of the first papers to
pick up our cultural affordances work
and in precisely the
context that you're proposing shannon
like um
what they're saying is uh our concepts
need to be enriched
with a kind of intermediate scale
concept
so their idea is like when you're when
you're performing live electronic music
there's something intermediary between
the field of affordances that each
individual
is coping with at any moment and this
evolutionary level kind of landscape of
affordances or this
population level uh landscape of
affordances where
there's you know the there are special
affordances that open up
in this uh performance uh context
kind of a a meso scale in between the
landscape and the field
uh i forget the precise term that they
that they introduced but
uh yeah the music is definitely one of
the cooler
domains of application of this uh this
stuff
nice sorry
all right shannon and then
just saying this is really great thank
you
cool sasha um yeah just a brief comment
to follow up on what alex said um uh
from the engineering perspective
you know if you have a hammer
everything's a nail it
kind of made me think uh about crime
where um if you need something and
you're not
um inhibited by uh law or social norms
you can just take it and
maybe that's a uh you know overly
simplistic understanding of
why people commit crime but in in that
context
if you're not inhibited by uh
laws then your affordances are quite
different
than if you are
okay and perfect richard you're uh
yeah in terms of the the field versus
the landscape
would it be accurate to kind of
conceptualize this the field of force is
kind of
the episodic knowledge of the individual
so what are their
their personal learned experiences their
personal body capabilities
kind of this really episodic self you
know um
form of memory where landscape of
performance is more about the semantic
knowledge the
if there was a way for me to kind of
look at the population and ask
what are all the skills and habits that
this population has
that would be the landscape if i was to
drill down on one person
how well do you know how to ride a bike
that would be more of your fuel
performance
precisely that's precisely the idea and
the idea
also is that not all affordances are
equally salient at a given time but
they're still there in a sense right
uh so i don't know like um
24 7 uh coffee shop there's times a day
where it's a salient affordance to some
people
well i was gonna precisely give a a food
and coffee related example
uh yeah i i drink coffee in the morning
but
i tend to uh have insomnia if i
if i drink it too late in the evening so
there are times in the day when
coffee affords drinking more than
other times in the day and so you know
it it's still the case that at any
moment i could go into the kitchen
and make myself a coffee right so
the field of affordances has more to do
with those those affordances that are
soliciting me at a given moment
uh you know it corresponds to the more
the phenomenology of interacting with
affordances
whereas the landscape is more an
anthropological or sociological
statement as as
richard you were just saying about the
kinds of things that a population can do
in a given space it that you talk about
that idea of sailings in the moment
because one thing we talk about a lot in
sociology is
is identity and so if you activate my
identity prime me to think of as a
professor
i'm going to notice certain things in
environment differently than if you
prime me to think of my identity as a
husband or a son
or a brother um so that kind of then
again but
identity means you know my identity as a
professor may be different from any one
of your identities as a professor based
on socialization
and culture and disciplines even as well
right so
okay interesting thank you yep and just
one point
to tie it back they write as high digger
famously
argued it is only when my smooth coping
breaks down
say when i run out of coffee or when the
cut breaks that the objective properties
the cup becomes salient
present in perceptual experience at all
and depending on if you're at home
you run out of coffee maybe you go back
to the coffee machine you set up a new
brew
if you're in a restaurant culturally
maybe you raise your hand or maybe
you whistle or maybe there's some other
thing that's done culturally to signal
that somebody else should see that as
their affordance
to come over and ask you what you need
so the landscape of affordances is a
very role specific
uh it's realized through specific roles
but it represents that population
level and that's so yeah lots to say
here that was an
excellent discussion let's turn to these
first two figures
that are cartoons about basic cognitive
formulas and a little bit more of a full
formula
so in this first three panel cartoon
i'll read out the captions and then
maybe somebody can give an example or a
thought
the first caption is the person thinking
i think they think i think the second
panel
says what would others expect me to do
here
and the third panel says i inferred that
they intend
that i should think feel or do x
so what is a thought or an
interpretation or a punch line to this
cartoon what would mommy want me to do
in this context and i you know
it's i think this is sociality is kind
of scaling that
up to an anonymous kind of third
or other or that is you know
yeah this kind of anonymous sociality is
kind of
scaling that like kind of you know
parental expectation thing
up a bit yeah it's like peer pressure
made me do it well yeah they
move your joints for you well no but
people expected me to do it
well just because they expected you to
do it even if that's true
why did you do it and it comes back to
this that
is an account of what peer pressure is
from from this perspective even if the
actual biophysics of the joints are not
being pushed by other people
and the the point that we're making here
i mean it's really developed in our bbs
paper uh thinking through other minds
but that
it's that human thinking really is not
just thinking about other humans
but thinking through their own
perspective
uh and that much of our social
interactions
actually are structured by
the beliefs that we have about
other people's beliefs about our own
behavior and beliefs
so you get this kind of nicely recursive
intentionality structure uh
yeah so that that's like the simple kind
of
you know the basic cognitive formula
that we're calling it but the
i we think that this really applies to
almost all human thinking
we're really always kind of trying to
understand the situation
uh from the perspective of you know
shared beliefs about what's appropriate
in that situation which which implies
the ability to kind of perspective take
and to think through the minds of others
yep
when someone's talking to hear
themselves talk as we say
it's off the rails because it's not in
feedback with other minds
but when somebody is attuned to the
narrative
and the culture of the local world the
local
actual interaction not just the
hypothetical
then there's the opportunity for
communication to be targeted
and direct and actually move towards
shared
goals and under shared values as well
instead of just individuals
biophysically running their mouth
which is an affordance that we also have
so how do we move
our communication patterns towards this
higher level
um instead of just using the
opportunities that we
know that we can also have any other
thoughts on figure one figure two is
related
is that we talk a lot about
perspectivism and
you know we go up to higher and higher
levels but i think
you see a point at which you can only
take a perspective on what you
think to a certain level it gets too
complex too multi-sensory too many
inputs
and it is that kind of phenomenological
embodied feel for what you need to do
which is not something you even have a
perspective on that idea of the flow
so there's this info inferential kind of
approach as well as a perspective
approach which just comes from
just feeling what you should do and i
think this this kind of shows that
because i think
you can only go up so far and take
perspectives on things
when how you act in the moment sometimes
you just have to be there
and feel it yeah and we can't perfectly
emulate
what somebody else wants and it's just
not that simple
we're in the bodies that we have with
the affordances that we see
and so to try to over engineer what the
other person
wants or should want or should want to
want it's
uh it's a good thought experiment
and it helps in a lot of situations but
it is not the end game of relating
well it might also explain some of the
difficulties that we're having currently
in our political landscape uh so i mean
as a as a canadian i'm very sold on the
idea of multiculturalism
and diversity and pluralism but
i think these are not intuitive modes of
sociality precisely because
uh they oblige us to multiply the
different perspectives
through which we're trying to you know
relate to
a shared social world um and you know
like uh
things like dunbar's number i'm sure
you're all familiar with
dunbar's number right if you if you uh
basically plot the size of primate
brains against the size of their social
groups there's almost a linear relation
and if you extrapolate that to humans we
would
you know live in groups of about 100
150ish
and you know the the that's
that probably has a lot to do with you
know the the kind of sweet spot where
it's easy to kind of share
uh you know a bunch of uh beliefs and
norms and patterns of behavior with the
group and things get more and more
complicated as the group expands and
diversity
is included which is not to say that
diversity is a bad thing by all means i
think uh
you know we should move in that
direction uh
but i think it speaks to some
difficulties
that we're seeing politically that it's
not an intuitive mode of sociality
cool we'll return to that when we can
and here in figure 2 we're almost
rephrasing figure 1 a little bit more
from an improvisational perspective
so the left panel the person is thinking
how much can i improvise here the middle
panel
is what do i know they know about me
right now
and how much room to improvise does that
give me
the third panel reads how much can i
improvise here
given what the local cues tell me about
what others expect
so a lot to say and think there's
probably other ways that these
recursive questions could be formulated
but is there anything that
we haven't addressed in one that people
might want to address here
cool this just reminded me of fellow
jitzer yes
yeah um i was i was thinking that um
maybe in the adolescent period
um we are kind of rebel
we are rebels against society and trying
to find
our identity um
maybe in other words um minimizing our
self prediction errors so we are
like trying to test
these norms um by being
uh level so actually by impairing
uh what others intend that i should
think
and feel maybe if i do the contrary
i'm going to learn something about me
so how can we
deal with this um like landscape
affordances and cultural affordances
or even what our mom is saying
and what we are really um
trying to find out um about ourselves
nice maxwell uh
oh well uh yeah uh uh so
i thought that was very insightful uh
thank you very much uh for that
very uh very interesting um well i would
have just added that
so the point here is to kind of say well
the it's it's not it's not merely just
about
you know inferring uh what others think
i should do
it's it's really more about the
situational coping
right so it's about like learning
different contexts and learning about
what's allowable
in all of these different contexts and
then being able to juggle that
and to reactivate the right
constellation
of you know semantic knowledge for
example or
rules and norms that pertain to each
context
and and also then you know moving from
one context to the next
and seeing what kind of flexibility that
allows for ultimately
uh because you know human reality is
improvisational
like it it's it's it's about kind of you
know uh
coping with uh with a situation
given the constraints of that situation
in real time
um yeah yeah it's a controlled novelty
question like a lot of improvisation
it's a on the edge
the leading edge of the trade-off
between explore and exploit where
successful
systems are at and so the teenage
rebellion
if the teenagers just mindlessly
fell into the line of whatever was
happening before
maybe in some niche that was unchanging
that would be a successful
evolutionary strategy but the niches are
always changing
not for the least of which is ecology
but also
improvisation has this always moving
dynamic and so the teenage
rebelliousness
is there's the element of the individual
coming to precision about who am i
and who am i in this broader sense and
then at the higher level there's this
explore exploit
where some element of contrarianism it
comes across like a
negative word but if you've ever had
contrarian models
then you couldn't know if you were just
in a very very local optima
or whether there are other realms to
explore
so there's there's so much there and the
details are all
in actually formulating these specific
situations and understanding
what are the affordances what is
precision uh
doing here so maybe in the next bit we
can
pretty briefly look through figures
three four and five
so maxwell it will be helpful to have
your perspective on these
but let's start with three so figure
three is
a hierarchical prediction error
minimization framework
and maxwell maybe could you give a shot
on what was being summarized here
sure um i mean we're just describing
uh bayesian predictive coding here
so most uh predictive coding schemes are
hierarchical as we were just discussing
uh above where um basically
what i mean this is more explained in i
think figure four or five
but essentially what this figure in
particular is supposed to illustrate
is uh the kind of bi-directional message
passing that's implicit
uh in in all of this so as we were
discussing you know the
top or the center uh is where the
more kind of abstract or slow
regularities
uh are represented and they they
effectively the the top layers
provide context for the bottom layers in
the same way that slow regularities
provide the context
or the embedding against which uh
you know faster regularities unfold well
these slower regularities or priors
provide context for the the ones below
so what you have descending
or you know coming from the center to
the periphery
is effectively predictions about the
kind of
data that each subsequent lower layer
should be receiving
and the way these schemes work uh is uh
i i think consonant with the
phenomenology
uh you know that so essentially if the
brain doesn't have to process
something then it doesn't uh the brain
is a lazy organ so the
the thing i i often say to drive this
home is what was the color of the last
door handle you opened
there's a large there's a high
probability that you didn't register
that at all
uh well because there's no reason to
right like you just smoothly coped
with with the door what you needed to do
is open the door to get to the other
side of it
and you know there was no reason to even
register the color of the door handle
so what with this kind of framework says
is the signal
that the brain is processing at any time
is the discrepancy between the data that
it was expecting to register
and the data that it actually does and
this difference is called a prediction
error
and uh if you can go just back to figure
3 for one second
um i just want to make the point that
well
so uh this relates to base in the sense
that
descending messages carry prior
probabilities
so essentially you can think of this as
the base rate for a given
phenomenon independent of the data that
i'm collecting
and then the prediction error kind of
combines that knowledge
with data so it's something like the
likelihood
if if the prior is just the probability
of
an event that i'm considering the
likelihood is the probability of that
event given
some data that i've actually uh
registered effectively
so this is why these frameworks are
often called bayesian
the ascending messages carry prediction
errors which are likelihoods and the
descending messages carry prior
probabilities which
which are the predictions that the
predictive brain and so on
are all about perfect
and then from here uh we move on to um
a specific hypothesis the predictive
coding
i'm not sure 100 the degree to which
we're still committed to this functional
distinction
but the idea is that um in at least in
the brain
they're going to be two kinds of neural
populations uh
the ones which encode effectively yeah
these generative model units
which are the ones that are encoding the
the kind of base rates
about the phenomena that you're
interested in and then another
uh functionally distinct sub-population
of neurons that's responsible for
computing the difference between the
data you expected given these
predictions
and the data that you're actually
receiving
and again the unexplained signal that
the part of the signal that wasn't
predicted by uh the descending uh
messages is passed upstream uh in the
hopes that it'll be explained away at
some point
and also one note that can help
understand this
is this caption in the empirical base
framework
the system can then use the posterior
obtained from one iteration as the prior
in the next iteration
and so the empirical base framework is
in a way what
it cuts the gordian knot it prevents us
from just saying well it's just simply
priors all the way up
and we start somewhere by starting our
prior
for one level with just empirically
what we're getting from the posterior at
the lower level at that time point
as a starting point and so this can be
instantiated in physical
not infinite systems because
there's a possibility that empirical
phase just as it's used in
data analysis in a variety of fields you
can use the data to inform a prior
and then have a generative model that
starts working from there
yeah precisely and what bayes does in
this context is just provide a way to
optimally combine
what you knew before sampling any data
uh
with what you've learned from that data
uh so as you're saying
uh what you're essentially doing is
multiplying your
posterior so you calculate your
posterior by multiplying your prior
by your likelihood and then uh
normalizing
uh which can get a bit hairy at times
but
that's effectively what you're doing
here and let's just look at this
example so here we have the same
architecture as
figure four so we're building it out
figure three this is a
uh it's a graph it's just nodes and
edges it's the pure
representation now we're thinking about
a little bit more of a plausible
neural architecture and maybe in some
brain regions it is this way and maybe
in other brain regions it isn't this way
but this is a plausible architecture
and now we have an example so what is
being shown with the dog
well this is just to re-illustrate the
center versus periphery distinction
uh well so the the image of the dog has
just
undergone a fourier decomposition
which basically means that you're kind
of separating out the different spatial
frequencies
uh that are used to generate the image
and
i mean the hypothesis is always sort of
the same is that the closer you are to
the sensory periphery
the the more you're dealing with faster
changing regularities
uh so high spatial frequency information
is represented at the bottom or the
periphery of the hierarchy
and as you ascend the hierarchy what you
see is essentially lower and lower
uh spatial uh frequency information
uh so this is the kind of idea here is
that like the
the the fast regularities are
represented closer to the sensory
periphery slow ones closer to uh the
center
uh yeah
i hope i said that right and um and and
yeah uh
most sensory modalities are gonna be uh
deconstructed in this way i mean you
know for the visual
uh brain regions uh you start off
you know detecting uh essentially lines
and you know like grading patterns and
the more primary
us visual areas like v1 and everything
and then as
you ascend the cortical hierarchy what
the neurons become
sensitive to are groupings of these
patterns so things that change at a
slightly slower
time scale i mean if you did one of
these fourier decompositions to an image
of the face what you'll see is that the
gross morphological features of the face
like you know where your cheekbones are
and where your uh you know jawline is
are much coarser than the fast changing
things in your face like your eyes and
your mouth uh
and so again you you might assume that
this is represented
hierarchically uh in the brain um
and let me see i'll add one more level
to the specific visual
example because it's in the specifics
that we can see
what we're getting out of this framework
so low spatial frequency
is like a blur filter it's a very uh
it's averaged out
over large regions of visual space on
in contrast the very high spatial
frequency it looks grainy
and that's kind of like turning the
contrast very high up to over
emphasize differences between
neighboring pixels but
when you do that you lose the global
structure so we know that from playing
around in photoshop
well it would be really cool if we could
just see the world in total
high resolution and just optimize this
with one level
but it turns out that in the retina the
cells are
activated even before the lines
detection it's like
light first dark it can only detect
whether it's on or off
extremely locally and so how does that
signal which is ultimately an extremely
local contrast
signal how does that percolate up in the
context of deep priors about
regularities in nature
to look at deep mind look at the images
that are produced in deep dream
these regularities that appear natural
they're not just any kind of natural
they're
human visual niche natural like grass
and clouds
these kinds of things have structures
that certain other kinds of repeating
uh like a grid just doesn't appear in
nature
and so this is a structure by which the
hyper local contracts
to contrasts literally between pixels in
this image
can be passed up and you can end up
getting this full spectrum
for your uh resolution on the image
and then to add one more level of detail
what we experience
isn't any single one of these levels
because we experience a world in full
color
though there's no uh color receptors at
our periphery
and also a world that's at full
resolution though we have very very
different resolution
as far as the pixels are uh
the retinal detection units are
concerned in this phobia in the center
of the eye versus the periphery
so that to me is demonstrative that
we're experiencing
our degenerative model of the world
which is that the world has similar
resolution no matter which way my head
is looking
and there's color everywhere and then
subconsciously or sub
personally our eyes are engaged in an
oculomotor
informational foraging task and where do
the eyes secade
it turns out that they look where the
most informative place to look would be
given the structure of this bayesian
algorithm so so many things that are
suggested with just this architecture
and there's so many aspects of
the signal processing cascade and
especially the top down priors
that aren't reflected by this idea that
the eye is a camera and the brain is a
cpu
and it's just doing image classification
like a convolutional neural network
there are convolutional elements to be
sure in vision but they're
playing out in this type of framework
not in a tic-tac-toe framework
yeah absolutely um couldn't agree more
with that that's
uh that's a great point i mean uh the i
think an
often overlooked element of this picture
is that it's not just saying
like this is a criticism of bottom-up
passive
you know a passive picture of the brain
that just kind of bottom up
aggregates uh you know simple properties
until you get something like a percept
it's so we're not just saying that this
is a top-down approach
it's the bi-directional processing
cascade that really gets you
uh where you want to go ultimately
and you know as you were just saying uh
dan like you know
the the experience that we're having
implicates all these different levels
and it's precisely because this whole
multi-level architecture is implicated
at all times that you get this kind of
rich
uh you know equally multi-level
experience
cool maybe we can turn to this last
figure
for the last section of our discussion
so now we've built out
this bayesian framework from the
previous images first from its most
austere
framing to something that looks a little
bit more naturalistic
and now we're going to bring it back to
our discussion about
culture and about expectations norms and
affordances
so here we have the same structure where
we have predictions moving
down and prediction errors moving up or
in or out these are just spatial
metaphors and there's only in and out
there isn't top or bottom
and then we're adding a few more levels
of details to the model
the first is this blue and that's the
precision
weighting and so that's entering this
hierarchy at a few different places
and it's tuning the temperature so to
speak
on the precision so how much should we
value how much stock should we take
about this
uh information that's coming up although
there's a lot more nuance there
and then also there's a top-down
modulation of attention
and that's where this regime of
attention enters so
the precision story is really key to all
this and you know honestly
as i was learning this framework uh you
know like five years ago initially i was
hoping that the precision stuff wouldn't
be so central to the argument because
it's really complicated
but uh it turns out that it you get you
get some of the most interesting
effects from uh the precision stuff so
it's it's it's a little bit
it's a little bit difficult sometimes to
wrap your head around but i think the
effort is worth it
the the idea is just to say at every
level of the hierarchy
the the brain doesn't just register a
signal but it evaluates how confident
or relia it is in that signal or how
reliable the signal is and this is what
this precision construct effectively
uh quantifies and you know uh dan you
were relating this to temperature
informally that's correct
uh a more intuitive way perhaps of
framing it is as
volume so it's sort of like the the
brain's volume
on each of its different kind of sensory
streams
so sensory and predictive streams
effectively
and yeah so uh precision waiting is what
uh allows you to according to this story
at least
arbitrate uh different sources of
information so for example 2018 2019 i
spent a lot of time in london
and london was surprisingly foggy um so
it it so far i mean as a canadian i
never experienced anything
like this i think once when i was a
child there was just so much fog
and there were days when i would come
out of my flat
in london and i couldn't see two feet
ahead of me
there was so much fog and so uh you know
in in circumstances like that what you
learn to do is to rely on your other
senses like you're hearing for example
so there's a
there's a story about the way that the
brain is kind of dynamically it's sort
of like a dynamic
balancing act in a sense the brain is
trying to
see which which of the signals that it's
dealing with
are the most reliable um so i'll stop
now richard has yeah
yeah so and this is the the criticism i
get a lot
uh when i present at conferences and
even when i publish on ideas related to
this
in the sense of you know if i'm let's
imagine i'm a master burglar
and i i walk into a neighborhood and i'm
looking i'm chasing the neighborhood to
find out what i want to
what i want to break into which house i
want to break into and so i have these
priors i had the sensory information
highly motivated to steal things and
then there's always that old guy in the
back who raises his hand and says that's
really cool so how do i test any of that
how what do i measure what variables do
i need to collect
and if at the end of the day all you're
giving me is a more refined version of
what i'm already talking about
who cares and i i my gut tells me that's
wrong that
i mean as we clean in all these
different disciplines we can go back and
forth and translate
you know our concepts back and forth and
see that we're all talking about the
same thing
but if it doesn't lead to something
empirical that then we can then start
doing critical tests
and show this version of the theory is
wrong because
my predictive priors or whatever would
have looked differently if it had been
that way
so i i guess like to me that's the thing
that i i'm always struggling with it and
i'm hoping i can get some insight from
everyone here is
how do we translate this figure six into
an empirical test that i can write up
for an nsf grant
and then gather data and show my theory
is right
parsons from 1950 was wrong right or
something
that's a great question um i think the
where this has been done
the most extensively is in psychiatry
uh where and this is why you know
uh this is what really drove the message
home for me
that the precision story was so central
to this
is that you can understand a lot of uh
psychiatric conditions uh in terms of
uh you know altered precision weighting
profiles
um so like uh
i think a kind of well understood
example has to do with the cycle the
course of schizophrenia
uh so we think that and phil corlet
uh has great work on this uh i mean
several people uh have worked on this uh
from different kind of perspectives but
all kind of relying on
this construct of precision and backing
it that
then backing it up with fmri data so the
course of
schizophrenia for example it's thought
to maybe start out as
a you know a break a physiological break
in your dopamine signaling so say d2
receptors
start to misfire for no reason so
they're generating
uh what we would consider to be a
spurious prediction error so like a
prediction error that isn't really
tracking anything
and initially this gets resolved
perceptually in the lower levels of the
hierarchy it's kind of contained through
hallucination
like the brain is generating a
prediction error signal and what it what
it ends up doing
is underweighting uh its priors are
overweighting
its prediction error uh because that's
essentially what's going on like there's
a breakdown and these prediction errors
that aren't tracking anything are given
too much
uh importance and as the condition
worsens they're given more and more
importance because they're consistent
like the brain is just consistently
generating this prediction error
and at some point it gets so it
intense in the brain that it starts to
be resolved through learning
rather than through a hallucination so
then you know
for those of you who do a little bit of
research in psychiatry you'll know that
there is a typical course of
schizophrenia that starts off as a more
kind of
hallucination experience where people
are still to some degree
cognizant of the fact that they're
they're undergoing an abnormal
experience and they're hallucinating
but late stage you know uh schizophrenia
has more to do with uh persistent
delusional beliefs
and now your actual cognitive structure
is adapting to the error signals that
you're generating and learning from
learning the error essentially uh which
is not tracking anything in reality
because it's just due to a breakdown
so from that point of view uh to answer
the
well to to address the points that you
just raised richard the
i think the uh like a lot of the power
of the approach
in terms of proof of principle comes
from psychiatry
these predictions uh and precisions
are are computed by parts of the brain
that you can identify
and so phil corlet i think in particular
has done uh some really really cool work
uh
on um on hallucinate uh on the
uh on schizophrenia and the uh
effectively the
kind of uh presentation of schizophrenia
and the chorus of schizophrenia
very cool work from that point of view
it feels at yale uh for those of you who
are
interested cool um steven and then we'll
return to the unique
predictions question yeah i suppose just
adding to that
um this this challenge of
things happening over time like a time
series of things happening
rather than kind of some snapshot in
time which i think
traditionally a lot of research sort of
does that so
even what maxwell was saying there is
what's presented as a pattern over time
if you took one moment it might not show
that and i think that's where
it's kind of hard to analyze that that's
why these
models that they create show how things
pan out over time on a low
dimensionality
and then you can get something from that
and i'm kind of
that does present a problem about real
life scenarios and i'm
my i'm interested in whether maybe
approaching it from the direction of
affordances and the environment and
working backwards
to how people are tuned to an
environment might be the way to look at
the more macro
because it becomes so high dimensional
if you take someone
at the individual level but i think this
is up for grabs
let's bring that back to the question
about
crime uh by richard so let's think about
the shared expectations
so the shared expectations might be
people don't
walk uh onto someone else's private
property so in that case even somebody
who's highly motivated and has the tools
the affordance to
do a burglary there's still uncertainty
about what's inside the house
now let's imagine changing the norm so
that people are have wide windows and
you can see exactly which house has
which
uh equipment now somebody who's
motivated and with the affordance
is enabled by a cultural norm that
allows passing close to the window
as well as an architectural affordance
to see inside the house
they're reducing their uncertainty about
what's inside of the house
and that is going to change not just
that agent's behavior
in their own field of affordances but
also some macro
trends and so this is in one sense this
is
looking at within the brain these are
different neuronal populations
and that would be precision could be
played by uh dopamine
and by dopaminergic synapses like
maxwell's talking about
and personally i find it fascinating
that so many stories about reward
like oh well gambling is about people
trying to maximize reward or
bank robberies about people trying to
maximize reward really
is it though or is it about people
optimizing their precision or perhaps
even operating under maladaptive uh
precision
regimes so it doesn't have just because
it's an optimization
and a precision oriented framework
doesn't mean that aberrant events
don't happen so within the brain level
we can think about that type of
precision
but then also socially what is the
feedback that somebody receives
along the way that have has other people
give them feedback to keep them
uh on the straight and narrow as it were
and then
how do we as cultures define what that
path is
are there on-ramps from the fringes of
society
that help onboard people into a healthy
and cooperative
way of living or do we push people who
even deviate in some way out of the
center where they're even more likely to
deviate further
from the increasingly narrow perspective
of the center so there's really so many
levels that this can come into play
at so i think just because of the time
let's have a few closing thoughts from
anybody who would like to share
and then also please through text if
you're listening as well as
participating
submit us questions or topics or quotes
because we have a bunch of quotes that
we've selected
and some other things that we felt like
we could have spent more time
talking about but we'll save that for
next week with this first week's podcast
being the figures the definitions the
on-ramps and the accessibility
from a lot of different fields and then
the next week we'll bridge out even
further
so any closing thoughts from our
participants
shannon i think that's a really good
point that question of how do you study
this
you know how how is how do you bring
this entire story of
the free energy principle or predictive
processing or act of inference and
actually study it in
a social context like in a group of
people so not just the stationary
burglar who's alone in a neighborhood at
night but
in the context of a group of people who
are interacting
and i think that would be a really great
topic for
part of next week or like when we
revisit
and just you know a plug from music
that's a great
uh little model system
to study these kind of interactions um
and
starting from western music just because
i grew up here and that's kind of music
i've interacted with but if you have an
ensemble you know
who are the leaders of the ensemble who
are the followers
and you can kind of manipulate that um
and
really study how you can play with
changing the regimes of attention or
changing
who in the group dictates uh what the
particular field
of affordance is that this piece of
music needs to play
um and there are a lot of really
exciting and fun ways to get creative in
the lab to study these kind of social
exchanges and maybe put some of these
um super complex mathematical models to
like bring it give it some empirical
testing
great richard anyone else can raise
their hand as well yeah
uh building off that i think that's a
great idea to talk about people in
groups and you know the things that i've
seen coming out with with hyperscanning
and the ability to have
two three four or five people all being
scanned at the same time whether
socially interacting and
and then asking okay so what is this
mathematical model
of the free energy principle or active
inference or whatever embedded an
individual
how does it what i mean does it come
down to a couple of oscillators i mean
that's the thing i keep coming back to
you is this right
this is just another version of coupled
oscillators and if that's
true then the notion of how do i
empirically deal with this is because
these coupled models can deal with 10 15
1 000 people interacting that our
current concepts in sociology we can
talk about abstractly but no one can
really figure out a way to measure it so
i think that'd be really interesting to
look at the intersection between the
models
our our current scanning abilities and
empirical design and the theory
and really see where they what are they
talking about and what is a more
unified you know operationalization of
these concepts
in light of this technology and these
models what would that look like in
terms of experimental design
that's really exciting um i'll i'll try
to rejoin uh
because my camera crashed again after
this comment but i wanted to say to both
of you shannon and richard if these are
lines of research that you're interested
in exploring this is definitely
something that my group is
very keen on exploring uh i mean you're
talking about hyper scanning i really
think this is the direction
ford uh we're working with uh a few
people
now uh so robin murphy
uh santiago castillo uh
in particular are all people who do eeg
and fmri hyper scanning
and uh the the new kind of thing that
we're trying to do is uh to combine
multi-agent
modeling with uh multi-brain
neuro imaging you know because the
problem with
that i have with social neuroscience is
that we're
and i'm sure those of you who do social
sciences will concur
they're what we're essentially doing is
looking at the brain with this
really deep level of you know
inquiry we're you know we're looking at
like
hundreds of different uh sensors on the
scalp or whatever
and so we have all of these this brain
data that we're looking at but really
when we're looking at like the kind of
social measures that we're using it's
it's these kind of toy measures like
empathy or whatever that are supposed to
tell us like something broad about
culture and the problem with that is
that we're effectively
flattening all of the causal structure
and complexity
of the social world onto these kind of
toy dummy variables that are supposed to
tell us something really deep about
uh you know social interactions and
uh by combining this multi-scale
perspective opened up by the free energy
principle
with uh hyper scanning and other uh
social neuroscience techniques
we're hoping to really be able to uh
talk about and understand and model the
social world
in all its complexity while also looking
at
uh brain dynamics so i have people for
example interact in
ecologically realistic situations for
humans
uh and then see stuff about you know
like uh
so edwileck for example if you don't
know her you should absolutely check out
her work
um e-d-d-a-b-i-l-e-k
edward she's currently carl fristan's
postdoc
uh and i think she's also at mannheim in
germany
and what she's developed is uh
effectively a measure of brain to brain
synchrony or uh brain tumor real-time
brain-to-brain information
transfer and you can get to this by
uh looking at basically real-time
interactions
between humans uh you know engaging in
some kind of shared
participatory task like you know
aligning gaze direction or whatever
and simultaneously recording their
brains as they interact
and i really think that this is like the
golden way forward so if any of you
actually are interested in pursuing this
please uh
send me a dm or something and we can get
started
perfect and i'll just close i think with
one short note on
flattening versus deflationary theory
because it really does come back to what
are we doing here
is this another metaphor and it's just
pendulums on a table
um or is there something actually more
here and flattening
maxwell was suggesting is when we're
just projecting that's psychological as
well as a dimensional term
we project onto simple constructs we
want to have a simple
concept of empathy and in a sense by
projecting into that representation
at a lower dimension we've created a
world that isn't necessarily reflective
of the whole system
in uh in contrast with a flattening
account
we can have a deflation a deflationary
account where what's happening is really
communicating brains
it's really just those brains
communicating and we're deflating away
the extra the second level where is the
empathy where's the regime
where's the attention the answer is it's
the whole system
and it's not just the whole system
meaning the person it's the whole system
with the niche and the culture
and so it's a lot to grasp grasp with
because
it is a multi-level system and we can
design an experiment that isolates
a certain component but we never truly
have isolated from the evolutionary
context or the developmental context
and so the goal to pursue
inflationary rich accounts that provide
all of these humanistic things that we
want to see
like inactive embodied in cultured
cognition
rather than flattening it onto something
and then saying well maybe they're the
same between different cultures
we can actually go into that richness
and
look at what we actually have and
stephen with a closing thought
yeah thanks i totally agree and i like
this idea of being able to
feel where we look this idea of feeling
texture
it would be sort of analogous to that
because you have empathy and someone
like i work a lot in the development
field and community work and
you get this idea of empathy but there's
no time variation and empathy it's just
like
dump there resistance and it's like well
how is that changing
moments moment isn't there's none of
that no one really thinks about that
how things change over time so i think
this this is actually really useful
it's clarified a lot of stuff in my head
actually just hearing
that discussion about i think it's a
different way of thinking about
looking normally all that granularity
would be seen
as a problem but actually it can be seen
as
data which is really cool beautiful
maxwell first author last thought
i just wanna it's less of a thought than
a feeling i just wanted to re-express my
gratitude to everyone in the
conversation
um this is really exciting and
awesome and uh like yeah
i i so if anyone does want to
develop these ideas like i was saying
please get in touch with me
and uh our our group is very keen on
collaborating with the we've established
a a multi-site
international network of research called
the nested minds network
uh we're gonna give uh we're gonna
launch the
website pretty soon but uh for those of
you who uh
are looking for international uh
collaboration
and so on please get in touch with me uh
like what we're trying to do is build a
community uh around this
and you know this podcast is definitely
part of the consolidation process
and uh yeah so thanks thank you all
uh you're all really cool and this is
really fun
thank you maxwell we built the on-ramps
together that are bigger than we can
build individually and
build the on-ramps we want to see we
build the culture that we want to see
and that's a lot of work to be done
but it's empowering to know that
together we'll make it happen
okay thank you all for the live stream
thanks for listening
and i will end the live stream